yeah hello
what do i say
hello
hello hello thank you for coming on i've
never spoken before
honestly how tired connor was before you
he just started like speed running man
he's like
are you already tired of me
why are you saying that
yes
yes
so emily do you want to introduce
yourself to our audience just in case
they don't know who you are hi my name
is emily i have the channel emmerichu i
just moved to japan a month ago you and
i'm a new member of geeksplus yeah boy
welcome to the family
i don't know why
it just just felt just not right you
know
um so i guess why
what why first question everything why
are you gay
so we're going to go way back to like
late 2019 right way back way back you
guys were actually well
we just moved yeah yeah
yeah we're just about to move to japan
yeah and i remember
uh
you me and didus were talking yeah and
we were like we gotta come visit you in
japan when you move it'll be amazing
we're gonna put tickets as soon as we
get home
so we book tickets for 2020 and we're
like all right we want to visit japan
and see connor it'll be great yeah and
then covet happened and uh
it kept happening
don't stop coming it will stop coming
i think around 2021
uh
yeah i think 2021 yeah yeah connor was
like hey would you guys be interested in
actually like moving to japan yeah and
that sounded like you know i'm not an
idiot that's a once-in-a-lifetime
opportunity i can't turn that down
sounds like a moment or something like
knocking on a door would you be
interested in moving to japan and
joining joining the culture
it's kind of like i'm melanie
yeah i was in like the middle where it's
like i can't like be like yeah you can
come here but i can be like i can ask
you and i can ask maylene i'm like is
this something that you would be
interested in if so i'll be like meline
these guys are good bring them over yeah
and then that kind of happened yeah yeah
so initially uh i was like well i want
to visit first because i've never lived
outside of the country before yeah yeah
i wanna you know like test the water so
have you ever been to japan before uh
yes actually a few years ago i visited
japan on like a guided tour so i don't
know if that counts but like it was for
a few days it was in osaka right okay
but that was like my last memory right
how old were you again
i was
23 24. okay okay i was like no when
you're like a child or something like
that no no no no no because you made
that yeah like i had no memories it made
it sound like you were like five yeah
when you're with you're like you're
doing anything i have no recollection
i'm just like
i've already got my [ __ ] old timers
you know when you visit any place with
your parents yeah it's your parents like
you can't have like a black i mean i
love my parents
but record your parents boring yeah no
okay i'm calling your parents now it's
like a guided tour yeah it was supposed
to be a mother-daughter trip right but
my dad gets major fomo
like he gets major fomo but he also
loves to complain all right so cute we
were like no i don't want like you're
gonna complain i already know you're
gonna complain the whole time
i just want this to be me and mom yeah
he's like no i want to come too and
you're like okay fine
and guess what he did the whole god
complain
i remember he went to kyoto we fed deer
and nara that was a lot of fun
yeah i want to go back
um
see i haven't done that that would be a
lovely memory tonight i've done that no
why
no it's like it's kind of far isn't it
well not if you're in all suckers it's
like it's kind of it's like an hour by
train that's kind of
oh you've been awesome how many times a
lot but normally i'm kind of enjoying
the night life yeah what a fun time see
that's a part i didn't get to enjoy that
is like what osaka is it's just like one
big like drunk mess yeah yeah but like
basically you know what when we're
talking
that's
[Laughter]
there isn't a whole lot to do in nara
yeah but like that's probably the
biggest like you know it's it's vicious
though right they're [ __ ] vicious
apparently since there's no tourists
right they've become very aggressive
yeah
they haven't have nearly as many people
as they would normally get so now when
you bring food they're like full on
attack yeah yeah
it's so so it's fun though i mean that's
like a really aggressive love from the
deer like they were already aggressive
beforehand right like they'd like chew
on your like jackets and like shirts i
remember witnessing it was so funny i
wish i recorded it but i remember
witnessing this like
old japanese woman and like my dear was
trying to eat her bag because it's not
me she's like fighting with it it was so
funny
also that sounds like connor's worst
nightmare because he's like [ __ ]
terrified of beers
i'm not scared of deers i just think if
they wanted to they could overthrow
humans you know
not those deers they're they're like
cutesy ones yeah they're the small i
mean the small this small the ones with
like big ass [ __ ] analysts and [ __ ]
those ones that like they're like that
you see how far they jump
yeah you can say that
so now that you moved it how does it
compare to like
all your nun memories i guess of like
visiting here before well i i feel like
because i was only here for what like
three four days well i was only in osaka
for like three oh okay technically i
didn't even get to see a whole lot right
so you didn't even go to like tokyo
other than the airport no oh really yeah
oh that's an interesting tool yeah so
here was just completely brand new to me
right right and it's been a really good
experience so far yeah i mean you're
obsessed with food so yeah the food is
so oh my god i had ochazuke the other
day
holy [ __ ] it's just tea with rice no no
no
it's rice
yeah well jessica it's like a like think
of like a pokeball kind of okay right
no that's not no you you're having the
fancy orchestras dude oh really yeah
yeah like normally or just don't wait
did meleen take you no
because normally ochazuke is literally
just like a you know a bowl of rice and
then you put green tea in it and you put
some foodie cookie on it and it's like
it's supposed to be like a breakfast
food no mine had like ikura it had sand
[Music]
like curry flavored potato salad on the
side no no no no you're not going to get
that
yeah that's all like you know at my
grandma's place she'd just be like
here's some rice he's a [ __ ] thing of
tea
breakfast
i guess before we get too much into
japan yeah
we should probably explain to the
audience more about you as well yeah i
want to know more about your yours
because they might not know what you do
so like what like on youtube you've been
doing what would you describe it because
dad has had
choice words
had his own words you just draw yeah i
like to illustrate uh stories of your
time you know my life i like to sure one
place
i'm sorry i'm sorry say it just say it
you're all just artists right it's all
different you're just you know yeah yeah
i like to also have conversations with
my friends and draw
over that as well it's a lot of i just
dropped that
good format that really took off yeah
because everyone was telling stories and
then i know a few other people did like
the whole have a conversation
that really took off yeah yeah i i those
are my favorite ones to work on yeah
just because they're always like it's
always the funniest
um yeah how'd you get started yeah when
did you start
oh man okay i started shortly after i
graduated college right um i graduated
with a degree in elementary education
and the next step was i had to receive
my credentials yeah i know right
i had to get my credentials to like be a
full-fledged teacher which meant like i
think like a year or half a year more of
schooling right i was really hesitant on
it because i was like i don't actually
want to be a teacher
right wait why'd you do that huh why'd
you do it because i so i've always liked
to draw but i assumed that i was not
ambitious or good enough to like make a
living off of it oh that's so sad
it's not that sad it was just like well
i i don't think i have what it takes
like both i feel that's a like a mindset
and a dilemma a lot of artists have yeah
right because it's like it's such a
competitive field yeah so the moment you
see like one person who draws better
you're like [ __ ] everyone around me
i hate [ __ ] i can't compete with this
because like even i suffer from like
imposter syndrome but like there it's
like not on the same level as like
basically every artist i've met who just
like it's it's so hard for you guys from
what i you know i've talked to you guys
that like you guys see someone and it's
so hard for like you guys not try to
mentally compare yourself to them even
you know that you know
even if it might be like a completely
different style yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
exactly i mean i don't i feel like i've
gotten to a point where i don't
automatically compare myself to other
artists yeah that's good it's more like
if they draw really good i'm like whoa
they draw really good whoa
now my dilemma is i'm worried of what
they think of me right right because as
an artist or as a person as an artist
there's so many artists that like are
amazing and they put their blood sweat
and tears into their art right but like
it's the social media game for artists
it's like really hard so even if you're
super good yeah if you don't have that
like i guess little bit of luck yeah
yeah yeah
and unfortunately like the rules of
social media is like skill is not
like it's not like a direct ratio to how
successful or how much engagement
artists will get on
youtube so like i know for a fact that
there's probably like artists out there
who are really good and they probably
look at my stuff and they're like
why the [ __ ] this is garbage how does
she how do you get don't think anyone
does that have you ever done that to
someone else's art no
but
i know i i i feel like it's very easy to
feel bitter when you work so hard and
yeah you don't see any progress yeah but
i feel like if you're taking that out by
you know being like oh why is this
person succeeding they're [ __ ] you feel
like that's
you're gonna have a bad mindset for
girls yeah no it's a terrible mindset
but yeah yeah yeah but i guess something
you worry about yeah yeah because i you
know when you're like the bigger you are
the more eyes that are on your stuff
yeah so there's you're always going to
have people being like you don't deserve
no of course of course yeah i think
that's true in like almost like every
creative industry like even even youtube
you know where you know you see some
very like special youtube yeah well you
see some very like very talented content
creators um and they have like [ __ ]
100 or like 500 subscribers and then you
see like a lot of um a lot of other
content creators who get a lot of [ __ ]
because it's on the surface it might
seem like they don't put as much effort
or they might they might not make as
much high quality content but there's
something that also works about their
content because unfortunately arts is
not just to do with like your skill sets
or how skillful you are or how good of
stuff you make a lot of times to do to
do with marketing as well yeah and like
how do you sell yourself yes it's
marketing and luck and those are like
like marketing especially is one thing
i've with i've met with a lot of artists
who are not the greatest app
unfortunately
and i'm just like you know what i wish
you knew how to market yourself better
because my god you guys you guys are so
talented yeah yeah so many people like
that definitely yeah i mean isn't like
the fine art world just like all
marketing and hype essentially
because it's not it's like you just need
to get in the circles right your name
has to be put in those circles yeah like
like hundreds of millions of dollars
like uh
yeah yeah because it's just like
you know once you know someone who like
owns a gallery or something
i feel it's a lot easier than someone
who's just you know painting in their
you know atelier and just like hoping
that someone will notice them one day
you know